[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURIE BAYET: My
name is Laurie Bayet.
I'm a postdoc at the University
of Rochester and Boston
Children's Hospital,
and I'm working
on developmental
cognitive neuroscience.
ALON BARAM: My name is Alon,
and I am studying currently
at Oxford.
I'm doing my PhD.
I'm there with
Professor Tim Behrens,
and I'm currently working
on computational cognitive
neuroscience.
LAURIE BAYET: Alon
and I are trying
to use paper by Tomaso Poggio
and Potters on a specific way
to achieve invariant
recognition in computer
vision or other algorithm.
So we're basically trying to
implement this in a simpler
case and then moving on
to our face recognition
under rotations.
ALON BARAM: The
idea is that most
of the variance in
computer vision,
when an algorithm tries to
discover what is in the image,
is held in very
few manipulation.
Like translation, which is a
shifting image across a field
or rotations or scaling.
So Poggio has a cool idea of
how to create this signature
that Laurie just
told about, which
is invariant to these things
and might reduce the sample
complexity.
So how many examples
you need to learn.
LAURIE BAYET: For
the simple case,
we just used an existing
data set of digits.
For the face data set, we tried
to find a suitable data set
online, but we
ended up just taking
videos of people using materials
provided by the summer school.
So taking videos of people
rotating their heads like this
slowly.
ALON BARAM: Yeah, it was fun.
LAURIE BAYET: Moving
around a little bit.
ALON BARAM: We have
now a complete data
set of the heads of people
from different angles.
LAURIE BAYET: We wanted
to provide the algorithm
with a hopefully limited
number of raw frames
from people rotating
their heads like this.
As a template, so to speak,
and act then as like a kernel
so to speak, to be
able then to recognize
unseen people under
various angles
so that whenever a
person is showing
this profile or
this profile, you
would still be able
to recognize it
with the same level
of accuracy as
if they were in front of them,
presenting the frontal face.
ALON BARAM: The purpose of
doing this project would
be, in the long run or what this
iTheory as Tommy Poggio calls
it will be in the
long run would be
to reduce the number of examples
that an algorithm, for example,
deep neural nets, the
number of examples
they need to see in order to
learn their weights in order
to learn how to classify
images or retrieve images.
LAURIE BAYET: We haven't
started the face part.
We only started the
digits part, which worked.
So we're--
ALON BARAM: It's
working basically.
We hope it will also work in the
endlessly more complex domain
of faces.
LAURIE BAYET: Now you know.
ALON BARAM: But we're hoping.
LAURIE BAYET: We're
reasonably optimistic.
I don't know.
We'll see.
ALON BARAM: Fingers crossed.
LAURIE BAYET: We've
approached the project
from pretty much
very different angles
but still ended up having
common interests, which
I guess is kind of hallmark
of this summer school too.
Alon has this other, very
interested in the engineering
problems, so to speak.
So how can we achieve
this with machines?
And I approached
the project from
a developmental perspective.
So given that the
current algorithms
manage to do invariant
face recognition based
on a fairly large
number of exemplars,
how come infants can
achieve this in a few months
based on a lot of experience,
but not that much--
mostly looking at their
parents, caregivers,
and a few other
exemplars, but not
like 3,000 people from
all possible angles.
So this is why I was very
interested in this theory
and trying to
implement this manually
has been pretty cool so far.
[MUSIC PLAYING]